et la deuxième partie elle va parler
essentiellement de chocolat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
battez vos meilleurs amis
voila j'aimerais quand même voilà
j'étais avec vous en tunisie il est
toujours avec moi c'est mon frère je te
voyais là les chromes commence à l'ua
mais souvent je suis exposé sur la tête
de ma mère à ce qu'il a dit une phrase
parce que moi je raconte tout il compte
faire son troisième film je vous le dis
il sera sur moi je peux leur dire ton
film je fais un tour le troisième film
il s'appelle ça sera sur la vie de cyril
ça va s'appeler la revanche du moche
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
moche qui se vengera qui devait rebours
avant verbaux il a la classe
defour donc un biopic sur serieslive des
idées auxquelles viviane et j'ai
d'accueil dans le titre foot moi j'adore
le type d'accord maintenant je suis né
là bas et que s'ils voulaient la wii
j'aimerais quand même peut-être que
comme c'est le meilleur ami si ce n'est
son meilleur ami il a peut-être quand
même quelques dossiers à balancer
raconte un dossier tout ça j'ai un
dossier c'est mort j'ai péché sa maman
on a mangé un petit couscous et sa maman
et j'ai je comprenais pas pourquoi cyril
été autant rapide autant speed
je me suis dit qu'est ce qu'il a il ya
pas eu un problème petit et sa mère je
peux leur dire sa mère m'a dit avery
terme a dit écoute cyril depuis l'âge
des îles à marcher à l'âge de deux ans
ah bon ouais le pire le pire c'est qu'il
a parlé à l'âge de deux ans mais non
c'était ça comme m'a dit serena
face à caen 2-1 les regarder les gens
c'est ça ton film parce que c'est ce
qu'on peut faire une interview sérieuse
elle a fait alors de quoi va parler ton
film bon je t'explique ce n'est pas dit
je vais même pas raconté ils doivent
bien d'ailleurs voir le film la première
partie va parler essentiellement
d'éducation nationale là c'est important
et la deuxième c'est la deuxième partie
elle va parler essentiellement de
chocolat je sais bien évidemment
[Musique]